we do have a David Show, sub reddit@davidpakman.com
slash r e. D d I t. That subreddit now has
more than 12,000 subscribers from our audience
regularly discussing politics and suggesting
stories for the show. Couple of notable discussions
from the subreddit one is an article referring
to the controversy around CNN having Richard
Spencer on their network to talk about Donald
Trump's tweets. And there have been a lot
of really, uh, comments that just miss the
mark on this Richard Spencer thing. The problem
is not that Richard Spencer appeared on CNN.
Okay. Importantly, this was like a couple
minutes segment and if I recall correctly,
Richard Spencer had like 15 seconds of air
time and he was commenting on how even as
a white nationalist, he sees these tweets
as counterproductive to their movement because
they are sort of just cartoonishly racist
and xenophobic rather than being this sort
of more sophisticated intellectual white nationalist
arguments that Richard Spencer likes to see
himself as being a purveyor or perpetuator
of, I don't believe the problem is that Richard
Spencer appeared on CNN. I believe the problem
is that he appeared in a context in which
his ideas were not challenged and it was sort
of included almost as like an expert on the
issue. And in a sense he is an expert on white
nationalists and that he is a white nationalist.
But I don't think it was a responsible platforming.
When I interviewed Spencer, I got emails from
people who just said straight up, you shouldn't
have them on.
Having him on is the problem. And of course,
uh, he had been on CNN previously. He had
been on our t, he had been on networks and
channels ranging from left to right. The interviewing
of Richard Spencer is not the problem. And
the sort of wholesale call to never talk to
him is not particularly productive in my view.
We need responsible platforming. That's what
CNN failed to do. And that should be the critique,
not simply. Spencer was interviewed. If you
disagree with me though, though, I would like
to hear from you, uh, an idea for what I should
be doing on twitch. I will have a little bit
of news, uh, later today about what I may
be doing on twitch soon. One idea is that
I should have a debate between Tim Pool and
Kyle Kalinsky about the Justice Democrats.
I don't know much about what's been going
on, but apparently there's been some kind
of dispute between Tim Pool and Kyle Kalinsky
about the Justice Democrats.
Now, many of you probably have never heard
of Tim pool, maybe not of Kyle Kalinsky and
maybe not of the Justice Democrats or one
or two of those you've not heard of. Uh, in
that case, don't even worry about it. But,
uh, these are the types of ideas that I think
are great to hear from the audience about
what could I be doing when I launched the
David Pakman show on twitch. Uh, more info
about that coming up a little bit later. Subscribe
for free to the Sub reddit@davidpakman.com
slash r e d dit.